FEMALE SPEAKER: The
following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we're
now starting to get
into a really familiar
territory, which
is the hydrogen atom.
And it's a short step from a
hydrogen atom to molecules.
And we're chemists.
We make molecules.
But one question that would be
a legitimate question to ask
is, what does a hydrogen atom
have to do with molecules,
because it's an atom and
it's the simplest atom.
And what I hope to
show is that what
we learn from looking
at the hydrogen atom
has all sorts of good
non textbook stuff
that prepares you for
understanding stuff
in molecules.
And I am going to stress
that because you're not
going to see it in McQuarrie
and you've probably never seen
it elsewhere except in freshman
chemistry when they expect
that you understand the
periodic table based
on some simple concepts.
And they come from
the hydrogen atom.
And so I'm going to attempt
to make those connections.
My last lecture was I told
you something you're not
going to be tested on.
But it's about spectroscopy.
That's how we learned
almost everything
we know about small
molecules and a lot of stuff
about big molecules too.
The crucial
approximations in that
were the dipole approximation
where the radiation field
is such that the
molecule field's
a uniform but oscillating
electromagnetic field.
In developing the
theory that I presented,
we assume that only one
of the initial eigenstates
is populated at t equal zero.
And only one final
eigenstate gets tickled so
that it gets populated.
And so even though there
is an infinity of states,
the theory specifies we start
with one definite one and only
one final state gets selected
because of resonance.
And this is what
we do all the time.
We have an infinite
dimension problem,
and we discover that
we only really need
to worry about a very
small number of states.
And then we deal with that.
There are a couple
other assumptions
that were essential
for this first step
into a time-dependent
Hamiltonian.
And that is the field is weak
and so you get linear response.
That means that the increase
in the mixing coefficient
for the final state is
proportional to the coupling
matrix element times time.
Now mixing coefficients
can't get larger than 1,
and so clearly we can't use a
simple theory without saying,
OK, we don't care about
the mixing coefficients.
We care about the
rate of increase.
And so by going from
amplitude to rates,
we are able to have a theory
that's generally applicable.
Now what I did was to talk
about a CW radiation field,
continuous.
Many experiments
use pulsed fields.
Many experiments use an
extremely strong pulsed field.
That I hope to revisit
later in the course.
But the CW probably is
the best way to begin.
So now let's talk about
the hydrogen atom.
We did the rigid rotor, and that
led to some angular momenta.
Well, let's just picture.
So we have this rigid
rotor, and it's rotating
about the center of mass.
And the Schrodinger
equation tells us
the probability
amplitudes of the rotor
axis relative to the
laboratory frame.
And we got angular
momenta, which
we can denote by a little l,
big L, J, and many other things.
And this is important because,
if it's an angular momentum,
you know it.
You know everything about it.
And you don't know yet that, if
you have two angular momenta,
you could know everything about
the interactions between them.
That's called the
Wigner-Eckart theorem.
That's not in this course.
But the important thing is,
if you've got angular momenta,
you're on solid ground and you
can do stuff that doesn't ever
need to be repeated.
And so one of the things that
we learned about the angular
momentum was that we have--
even though it's going to be L
as the angular momentum mostly
in the hydrogen atom,
I'm going to switch to J,
which is my favorite notation.
So J squared
operating on a state--
now I can denote it like this
or I can denote it like this.
It's the same general idea.
These are not quite
equivalent things.
And you get H bar
squared J A plus one JM.
And we have JZ operating on JM.
And you get H bar M JM.
And we can have J plus
minus operating on JM.
And that's H bar times
this more complicated
looking thing, J plus 1
minus M, M plus or minus 1.
So that's the only bit
you have to remember.
And you might say, well,
is it plus or minus 1
or minus or plus 1?
And so if you choose--
M is equal to J. Then
you know that if you
have M is equal to
J, this is going
to be 0 if we're doing
a raising operator.
And so there's
nothing to remember
if you are willing to go
to an extreme situation
and decide whether it's
plus minus or minus or plus.
Now the rigid rotor is
a universal problem,
which is solved.
It deals with all
central force problems.
Everything that's
round, the rigid rotor
is a fantastic starting point.
So one-electron atoms for sure--
many-electron atoms, maybe.
We'll see.
But anything that's
round, the rigid rotor
is a good zero point for
dealing with the angular
part of the problem.
So for the hydrogen atom,
we have a potential.
It looks like this.
And so the radial
potential is new.
For that rigid rotor, the
radial potential was--
it's just 0 for the
R is equal to R zero.
And not zero-- then the
potential is infinite.
Now here we have
potential, which
doesn't go to infinity here and
it does something strange here
because you can't
get to negative R
in spherical polar coordinates.
So is it a boundary
condition or is it
just an accident of the
way we use coordinates?
So we're going to apply what
we know about angular momenta
to the hydrogen atom.
So our potential for
the hydrogen atom
is going to be
expressed in terms
of the distance of the
electron from the nucleus
and then the theta phi
coordinates, which you already
know.
And the theta phi
part is universal,
and the R part is special
to each problem that
has physical symmetry.
And there are different kinds
of approximations you use
to be able to deal with them.
The nice thing about it
is it's one dimensional,
and we're very good at thinking
about one dimensional problems.
And even if the problem
isn't exactly one dimensional
or it has some
hidden stuff to it,
we can extend what we know
from one dimensional problems
and get a great deal of insight.
And if you have a one
dimensional problem,
it's very easy to describe
the potential in one dimension
and the eigen functions
in one dimension.
And so we can begin to
really understand everything.
So we're going to have a
wave function, which is
going to have quantum numbers.
And we're going to
be able to write it
as a product of two parts.
Well, this is the same thing we
had before for the rigid rotor.
So we're going to be able
to take this rotary equation
and separate the wave function
into two parts, a radial part
and an angular part.
And this is old and this is new.
Because we've got this, we
can use all of that stuff
without taking a
breath, except maybe
getting the right letter
L, J, S, whatever.
So really the hydrogen
atom is just one thing
with some curve balls thrown
at you in the latter stages.
One of the things you also
want to be able to do--
because nodes are so
important in determining
both the names of the
states and how they behave
in various situations, including
external fields and excitation
by electromagnetic radiation--
you want to be able to
understand the nodal surfaces.
And you already know this one.
So how many nodal
surfaces are there
if you have a
particular value of L?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: L.
PROFESSOR: Right, and if you
have a particular value of M,
how many nodes are
there in the xy plane?
You're hot--
AUDIENCE: I mean,
I know if M is 0,
the entire angular momentum
is tipped into the xy plane.
So that means that
the axis of the rotor
has to be orthogonal to
the angular momentum.
So that means that the
probability density is
oriented along Z, I think.
PROFESSOR: Now
you're saying things
that I have to stop
and think about
because you're not telling
me what I expected to know.
So if M is equal to
0, L is perpendicular
to the quantization axis,
and there are no nodes.
AUDIENCE: Well, it
depends on if you're
talking about the nodes
of the probability
density of the rotor,
where the axis is.
PROFESSOR: That's true,
but where the axis
is determined by theta.
And when theta is equal to pi
over 2, you're in the xy plane.
And the number of
nodes in the xy plane
is M, or absolute value of M.
The phi part of the rigid rotor
is simple.
It's a differential equation
that everybody can solve.
We already know that
one, and we know what
the wave functions look like.
We can write the hydrogen
atom Schrodinger equation,
and it's very quick to show
separation of variables.
And I'll do that in a minute.
And then we have the pictures
of the separated parts--
RNL of R and YLM of theta phi.
And essential in these pictures
is the number of nodes.
In the spacing between
nodes, remember
the semiclassical approximation.
We know that Mr. DeBroglie
really hit it out of the park
by saying that the
wavelength is H over P.
For every one
dimensional problem,
we know what to do with that.
And we're going to discover
that, for the radial problem,
we have a very simple
way of determining
what the classical momentum is.
And so we know everything about
the nodes and the node spacing
and the amplitudes
between nodes and how
to evaluate every integral
of some power of R or Z.
And so there's just
an enormous amount
gotten from the
semiclassical picture
once you are familiar with this.
And so we can say that we
have the classical wavelength,
or the semiclassical wavelength.
It has an index R. So we have
a momentum, a linear momentum
with a quantum number
on it for L. See,
that's a little strange.
But that tells us what the
potential is going to be
and that tells us
what to use in order
to determine the wavelength.
And this is really
the core of how
we can go way beyond textbooks.
We can do-- in our heads or
on a simple piece of paper,
we can do this.
And we can draw pictures, and
we can evaluate matrix elements.
Without any complicated
integral tables,
you can make estimates that
are incredibly important.
And from that you can get
expectation values and also
off-diagonal matrix
elements of integer
powers of the coordinate.
That's an enormous amount
of stuff that you can do.
Now you can't do it yet.
But after Wednesday's
lecture, you will.
And so this will be Wednesday.
And then we'll have
evidence of electron spin.
And I will get to that today.
So this is the menu.
Now let's start delivering
some of this stuff.
I have to write
some big equations.
So the Hamiltonian is kinetic
energy plus potential energy,
and kinetic energy was--
I'm sorry.
For the rigid rotor, V was zero.
And everything was in
the kinetic energy.
Well, it's not quite true.
And so, for
hydrogen-- so we know
this is P squared over 2 mu,
and mu for the hydrogen atom,
reduced mass.
And we know this is just
Coulomb's Law, minus e
squared over 4 pi epsilon
zero R, H bar squared.
I'm sorry-- it was
supposed to be e squared.
So this is the classical--
So these are the parts.
But the since it's
spherical, we're
not going to work in
Cartesian coordinates.
And in fact, that's a
very strong statement.
If you have a spherical
problem, don't
start in Cartesian
coordinates because it's
a horrible mess transforming
to spherical polar coordinates.
Just remember the spherical
polar coordinates.
So you know how spherical
polar coordinates work.
I'm not going to draw it.
So the kinetic energy term is--
and this is the Laplacian,
and that's a terrible thing.
And Del squared--
it looks like it's
going to be a real nightmare
partial with respect to R,
R squared partial with respect
to R. And we have 1 over R
squared sine squared
theta partial with respect
to theta, sine theta partial
with respect to theta.
And then a third term--
1 over R squared sine squared.
I got a square here.
That's wrong.
And this is sine squared theta.
I heard a mumble over there.
Yeah, but I'm just
doing Del squared.
AUDIENCE: With your first
Del, it's H plus squared.
PROFESSOR: My what?
AUDIENCE: Your first time you
used the Del operator, it's H
plus squared.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: And then
the second one,
if you could clarify
that that's a Del--
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: The
second Del squared,
if you could clarify
that's a Del squared.
It looks like a--
PROFESSOR: It looks
like a terrible thing.
And the last part is a second
derivative with respect to phi.
This looks like a terrible
thing to build on.
But with a little
bit of trickery--
and that is, suppose we multiply
this equation by R squared--
then we have killed the R
squared terms here and here.
And we're going to be
able to separate it.
And so we are able to
write an equation which
has the separability built in--
and so partial
with respect to R,
R squared partial with
respect to R plus L
squared plus 2 mu H R
squared V of R minus E psi.
That's a Schrodinger equation.
So we have an R dependent term
and another R dependent term
and a theta phi dependent term
all in this one, nice operator
that we've understood.
So now there's one more trick.
In order for the
shorter equation
to be separated into a
theta phi part and an R part
is we need a commutator.
And so that commutator is this.
What is a commutator between L
squared and any function of R?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Their operators
depend on different variables?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely,
that's really important.
We often encounter
operators that
depend on different variables.
And when they do, they
commute with each other,
which is an incredibly
convenient thing because that
means we can set up the
problem as a product
of the eigenfunctions of
the different operators.
So this means that we can
write a theta phi term, which
we completely know, and an
R term, which we don't know
and contains all of
the interesting stuff.
So let's forget
about theta and phi.
Let's just look at the R part.
Well, the way we
separated variables,
we had the Schrodinger
equation and we
divided by the wave
function, which would be
of R of R, Y L M of theta phi.
And on one side of the equality,
we have only the angle part.
And so when we do that,
when we divide by R,
we kill the R part on this side.
And on the other side,
it's the opposite.
And so we get two pieces--
one is only dependent
on theta and phi
and one is only dependent
on R. So they both
have to be a constant.
So we get two separate
differential equations.
And we've already
dealt with one of them.
So what you end up getting
is 1 over R of R times stuff
times R of R is equal to
1 over YLM L squared YLM--
sorry.
So this is the separation.
This is all R stuff.
This is all theta stuff
and separation constant.
Well, this one is inviting
a separation concept
because L squared
operating on YLM
is H bar squared, LL plus 1.
That's the separation constant.
So now let's look
for the only time
at the R part of the
differential equation.
And so this writing out
all the pieces honestly--
we have-- there's one more.
So that's the Schrodinger
equation for the radial part.
It looks a little bit annoying.
The important
trick is that we've
taken the separation constant,
and it has an R dependence
but when we divide through
by 2 mu HR squared.
And we say, oh, well, let's
call these two things together--
VL of R. This is the
effect of potential,
and it depends on
the value of L.
So this is just like an
ordinary one dimensional problem
except now, for
every value of L,
we have a different potential.
And this potential is--
OK, when L is not equal
to zero, this potential
goes to infinity at
R equals 0, which
is bad, except it's good because
it keeps the particle ever
from getting close
to the nucleus.
And that's what
Mr. Schrodinger--
I'm sorry what Mr. Bohr
was thinking about,
that we have only
circular orbits
or we have only orbits that
are away from the place
where the Coulomb interaction
would be infinite.
And I mean, there are
several things that's
wrong with Bohr's picture.
One is that we have orbits.
And the other is that we
don't include L equals 0,
but this is telling you a
lot of really important stuff
because the value
of L determines
the importance of this thing
that goes to infinity at R
equals 0.
And that has very significant
consequences as far as
which orbital angular momentum
states we're dealing with.
So we're going to get the
usual LML quantum numbers,
and we're going to get another
one from the radial part.
And since this is a
1D equation, there's
only one quantum number.
And we're going to
call it L. And now
there's this word principal,
and there's really two words--
principle with an LE and
principal with an AL.
Which one do you
think is appropriate?
I'm sorry.
I can't hear.
AUDIENCE: AL.
PROFESSOR: AL is
the appropriate one.
Principle has to do with
something fundamental.
Principal has to do with
something that's important.
And I can't tell
you how many times
people who should know better
use the wrong principal.
You'll never do that now
because it was like, what's nu?
C over lambda.
So this is the right principal.
If we do something clever
and we have the radial part
and we say, let
us replace it by 1
over R times this new
function chi L of R, well,
when we do that, this equation
becomes really simple.
So what we get when we make that
substitution is H bar squared
over 2 mu H second derivative
with respect to R plus VL of R
minus E chi L of
R is equal to 0.
That looks like a differential
equation we've seen before.
It's a simple one dimensional
differential equation--
kinetic energy,
potential energy.
But it's not.
There's some kinetic energy
hidden in the potential energy.
But this is simple, and we
can deal with this a lot.
I'm not going to.
But if you're going
to actually do stuff,
you're going to be wanting
to look at this differential
equation.
But I'm going to
forego that pleasure.
One of the problems
with the radial equation
is the fact that R is a
special kind of coordinate.
It can't go negative.
And so treating the boundary
condition for R is equal to 0
is a little subtle.
And it turns out that when
L is equal to 0, then R of 0
is not 0.
But for all other values
of L, R of 0 is 0.
And all of NMR
depends on L being
0 because the electron
feels the nucleus.
It doesn't experience
an infinite singularity.
It feels the nucleus.
And when L is not
equal to 0, then it's
sensing the nucleus
at a distance.
And that leads to some
very small splittings
called hyperfine.
And so there's different
kinds of hyperfine structure.
But anyway, this is a really
subtle and important point.
How much time left?
Yes?
No.
So now pictures of orbitals--
So the problem with
pictures of orbitals
is now we have a function
of three variables
and it's equal to
some complex number.
So we need two
degrees of freedom
to present a complex number
and we have three variables.
And so representing that on a
two dimensional sheet of paper
is horrible.
But we have this
wonderful factorization
where we have RNL of R. And
we could draw that easily.
We don't need any special skill.
And we have YLM of theta phi.
And we've got lots of
practice with that,
although what we've
practiced with
may not be completely
understood yet.
So we have ways of
representing these.
And so we go through
the understanding
of the hydrogen atom by looking
at these two things separately.
Now for the radial part,
the energy levels--
where this is the
Rydberg constant.
It's a combination or
fundamental constants.
And for hydrogen,
the Rydberg constant
is equal to 109,737.319--
there's actually more
digits, wave numbers--
times mu H over mu infinite.
Well, this is actually
the Rydberg constant
for an infinite mass.
And so mu H is equal to
the mass of the electron
times the mass of the proton
over the mass of the electron
plus the mass of the proton.
Now the mass of the
proton is much bigger
than the mass of the electron.
And so you can use
this as a trick.
You can say, well, what is it?
Well, we know what this is.
It's easy to calculate.
But there are two limits.
What is the smallest
possible reduced mass?
And that would be for--
if the mass of the
proton is infinite,
then we just get the
mass of the electron.
That's the biggest reduced mass.
And the smallest is,
if we have positronium,
where we have an electron
bound to a proton--
and then when we do
that, we get half.
I'm sorry.
It's not a proton.
It's a positively
charged particle,
which we call a positron.
And so each of the terms here
is the mass of the electron.
And so the range is
from 1/2 me to me
depending on what particles
you're dealing with.
And so that's a useful thing.
And so the Rydberg
constant for hydrogen
is smaller than the reduced
mass of the infinite.
I'm sorry.
It's smaller than that for
the infinitely mass nucleus.
And it is the value that
made Mr. Bohr very happy--
679.
So the important thing
is this mass scaled,
or reduced mass scaled, Rydberg
constant explains to a part
in 10 to the 10th all the
energy levels of one-electron
systems--
hydrogen, helium
plus, lithium 2 plus.
That's it.
And that's fantastic.
Now we have to talk to
become really familiar
with this Rnl of our function.
And one of the questions
is, how many radial nodes.
And you know that for 1S
there aren't any nodes.
And you know for 2P there
aren't any radial nodes.
And so what we need
is something that
goes like n minus L minus 1.
The number of
radial nodes, which
is all you need to know
about the radial A function,
is how many nodes are and
how far are they apart
and what's the amplitude
of each loop between nodes.
Semi classical theory
gives you all of that.
And often when you're
calculating an integral,
all you care about is the
amplitude in the first loop.
And so instead of having
to evaluate an integral,
you just figure out what is
the envelope function based
on the classical
momentum function.
Now the thing that
everybody's been waiting for.
Spin.
So remember, we know an
angular momentum is R cross P,
and we know that there isn't
any internal structure.
Or at least we don't know
about internal structure
of the electron or a proton.
And so we can't somehow
say, well, it's R cross P.
So we have the Zeeman effect.
So we can look at
the Zeeman effect
for an atom in a magnetic field.
And we have several
things that we know.
So we have the magnetic
moment of the electron
is equal to minus the charge
on the electron times 2ME times
L. Well, that's an
angular momentum.
So if we had circulating charge,
well, that circulating charge
will produce a magnetic moment,
which has a magnitude which
is related to the velocity.
And what is L divided by mass?
It's a velocity.
And we have the charge here.
So this is a perfectly
reasonable thing.
And that's good because we
know that, if we have electrons
with some kind of
internal structure,
we know what this
is going to do.
Now the magnetic potential
is equal to minus
the magnetic moment times
the external magnetic field.
And so what we have is
E, BC, LZ over 2 NE.
Well, this is another
very good thing
because, not only do
we know what this is,
we know that it has
only diagonal elements.
And so we can do first
order perturbation theory.
If this is so easy, if
this is the Hamiltonian,
we can just tack that on and
it adds an extra splitting
to our energy levels.
The only tricky thing is,
we don't know that it's LZ.
We just know that it
has a magnetic moment
or it could have
a magnetic moment.
And so this wonderful
experiment--
suppose we start
with a 1S state,
and you go to a 2P state.
Now this implies that
we know something
about the selection rules for
electromagnetic transitions.
And so for an electric
dipole transition,
we go from 1S to 2P.
Now this is not how
it was done initially
because the frequency
of this transition
is well into the
vacuum ultraviolet.
And in the days when quantum
mechanics was being developed,
that was a hard experiment.
So one used an S to P
transition on some other atom,
like mercury, but let's
pretend it was hydrogen.
So this is an angular
momentum of 0.
So we would expect it
would be ML equals 0.
And here we have it could
split into three components.
And this is an L equals 1, 0
minus 1, because that's minus--
there with a minus
sign somewhere.
That's what we expect.
And so being naive, you might
expect transitions like this.
Well, the transitions
where you do not
change the projection
quantum number
are done with Z
polarized radiation.
And so if it's Z polarized,
you get only delta ML equals 0.
And if you have x
and y, you have delta
ML equals plus and minus 1.
So depending on how the
experiment was done,
you would expect
to see one, two,
or three Zeeman components.
And they did the
experiment, and they
saw more than three components.
They saw five components.
And that's possibly for
a number of reasons.
But they saw five components.
So they knew that there was
something else going on.
And so you have to try to
collect enough information
to have a simple minded picture
that will explain it all.
So one thing you
might do is say, OK,
suppose there is another
quantum number, another thing.
And we're going to call it spin.
And we don't know whether spin
is integer or half integer.
We know from our exercise
with computation rules
that both half integer
and integer angular
momentum are possible.
And so we can say
we have a spin.
And it could be 1/2.
It could be 1.
It could be anything.
And then we start looking at
the details of what we observe.
And what we find is,
all we need is spin 1/2
to account for
almost everything.
However, if it were spin
1/2, then you get two here.
And you'd get two here,
two, here and two here.
And that's six.
That's bigger than five.
So you need to know
something else.
And one thing is quite
reasonable-- you can say,
well, the spin
thing is mysterious,
and electromagnetic
radiation acts on the spatial
coordinates.
And there aren't any
spatial coordinates
of the internal structure
of the electron.
And so we have a selection
rule delta MS equals 0.
That still doesn't do it.
You still need
something else, and that
is that the proportionality
concept between the angular
momentum and the energy,
which is called the G factor.
For orbital angular
matter, the G factor is 1,
or the proportionality
constant is 1.
So the G factor is L. And
the G factor for the electron
turns out to be 2--
not exactly 2, just a
little more than 2--
Nobel Prize for that.
And so with those
extra little things,
then every detail of the
Zeeman effect is understood.
And we say, oh, well, the
electron has a spin of 1/2,
and it like it acts like
an angular momentum.
It obeys the angular
momentum computation rules.
It also obeys the
computation rules.
Well, I won't say that.
So I should stop--
there are other things
that provide us information
that there is something else.
And one, I'm called by some
people the spin orbit kid
because I've made a whole lot
of mileage on using spin orbits
splittings.
And the spin orbit
Hamiltonian has the form L.S
And this gives rise to
splittings of a doublet P
state, for example,
as what you would
see in the excited
state of hydrogen
into two components
at zero field.
And so there's all sorts
of really wonderful stuff.
And I'm going to cheat you
out of almost all of it
because we're going to go over
to the semiclassical picture
next time.
And we'll understand
everything about Rydberg states
and about how do we
estimate everything
having to do with the radial
part of the wave function.
And there are some
astonishing things.